[Applause]
good morning Hank it's Friday I got up
around 5:30 let's go put this stuff in
this bag and printed out my itinerary
Willie always knows what I'm leaving
Maryna drove me to the airport I'm
marina which was mostly empty and I took
off for Atlanta I read a good book on
the way landed in Atlanta where I had a
couple hours to kill I always look for
interesting places in airports like this
tiny Interfaith Chapel where someone had
inked in the direction of Mecca and
Martin Luther King's Nobel Peace Prize
and this portrait of Chewbacca's
silhouettes straddling the galaxy and
this lady whose knee is apparently
delicious then I got on a plane to
Munich and kept glancing into the aisle
nervously hoping that no one would sit
next to me and no one did so I took a
sleeping pill but it didn't work and
three hours later I found myself
delirious in the airplane bathroom with
a camcorder
the flight lasted nine hours and I never
fell asleep but I did get to see the
sunrise from 36,000 feet above the
ground and it occurred to me that until
a century ago no one in all of human
history had ever seen that then we
landed in foggy Munich and I had a
pretzel I was by this time somewhat
worse for the wear my mouth tastes like
dead rat but then I was flying to
Amsterdam the city I loved most in the
world I loved it's adorable kissing
doors and I loved its parachuting
Christmas donkeys it's by cyclic
abundance it's humorously small trash
cans it's gorgeous canals it's
apparently modest prairie dogs its vamsi
frites it's uncommon ly well balanced
citizenry and it's beautiful old canal
houses like all great cities Amsterdam
brims with contradictions maps of the
red-light district are dominated by a
church swans swim up the canal while on
the banks of that canal a woman stands
half naked in front of a glass door
waiting for customers Amsterdam is both
the city that hit Anne Frank and the
city that gave her up an ancient city
perpetually experiencing new
construction a city full of boats that
separate you from water and contain
water these same contradictions are in
all of us are there in me at least and
so I forgot that I've been awake for 30
hours and kept walking grateful to be a
little boat full of water still floating
Hank I'll see you on Monday